this is Jonathan Ferguson keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and in
this week's episode Jonathan is taking a
look at some of the weapons found in the
campaign of 2022's Call Of Duty Modern
Warfare 2. and I've now been presented
with a truly horrific
because of course uh gold-plated and
Chrome plated
Abomination that I'm now going to have
to look at make sure to subscribe if you
want to see Jonathan's take on the
game's multiplayer weapons as we'll be
throwing him some cursed and customized
Creations to react to as well and if
you'd like to help out the Royal
armories Museum and continue to support
Jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right
let's take a look at some of the weapons
from Modern Warfare 2.
foreign
this is a Call of Duty Modern Warfare
staple what I'm going to call the AR-15
although I know for quite specific legal
reasons uh not much to do with this game
but all games the term AR-15 remains
trademarked M4 Isn't So hence discussion
of M4 platform this isn't part of the M4
platform exactly because it's different
here is a real one this is a Daniel
Defense ddm4 V7 so it's pretty
up-to-date certainly for a museum it's
got a very different for end on it it's
it's uh cylindrical is not M lock which
the one on screen appears to be that's
that's a squared off type of slot looks
like a cooling vent it's actually for
attaching
of rail just like we see on the screen
there in fact this one is set up a
little similarly so this is maybe the
closest we've got to this with a bit of
Magpul furniture on it not the pistol
grip but the butt stock at least and
without that distinctive triangular
front sight block of the AR15 M16 M4 and
you can see on this one you don't have
that massive
extra sort of fence above the trigger
guard
and then coming up this existing
reinforcing Ridge that's what this is
and there's that round round section
classic AR upper because this is all the
bolt is the bolt carry group is tubular
buffer tube is tubular everything is
tubular and so typically this is a round
rounded outer section not so here plenty
of AR receivers do have that faceted
look to them perfectly believable and
plausible as a model AR-15 but not a
real world one they've gone their own
way with it but there's nothing sticking
out as wrong someone could make this in
the real world and it would sell
broke with me
right next up we have the Chris Vector
well sort of this is are we gonna have
one so I can't show you that what I mean
by this but I can tell from the sheer
width width of the magazine versus the
magazine well and what is meant to be
the lower receiver of the gun this
thing's far too skinny to accommodate
that very interesting v-shaped bolt in
the Chris Vector so this this wouldn't
work the bolt has to have space to come
back and down
and have space for the dock pattern
magazine to go up into and there isn't
really this this thing this lower part
in front of the trigger guard should be
maybe as much as twice as deep otherwise
it looks okay
um it looks very rectory so it's a
curious as ever I don't know if it's a
mistake or if it's a deliberate choice
to distance it from the real design
dimensional issues aside this thing
looks to handle pretty well it seems to
given that it's 45 ACP so a little bit
more of a felt recoil punch it does seem
to emulate the real vectors subjectively
reduced recoil well it's more than
subjective I think um the the sort of
the overall design of it and something
about the delay of that bolt coming down
does does seem to help in automatic fire
everybody
[Applause]
all right well we we cover the um the
infamous Stegall in this series so often
that I almost left it left it on behind
in the drawers but uh it felt wrong so
here it is
uh desert eagle Mark I think we're on
the mark 19. the one in the game has top
and bottom Picatinny rails this has the
old style two-notch Weaver pattern rail
from the old days because this is a
relatively old there's the eagle but
it's of the same Mark and then they sort
of stopped changing the mark and just
changed the gun anyway so you get
different barrel lengths you get
compensated and barrels the rails have
just sort of crept in without there
being a change to the mark As far as I
know and then we have the the
horrifically pimped one with the sort of
titanium nitride gold barrel and con
massive compensator Target sights
red hammer weird machined custom slide
I'm not aware of stuff like that for the
Desert Eagle but I'm sure someone's
doing it maybe not exactly the same as
that though
[Applause]
all right
all right a little bit of a head
scratcher here although I think a
version of this has been in the series
before so before we get to my issues the
magazine on the top of this thing
clearly
p90-esque is trans semi-tran
semi-translucent or is translucent
semi-transparent you can see the round
in there they look quite like 5.7
millimeter rounds they are depleting the
follower is moving as the gun is fired
probably one of the better
representations of the P90 magazine feed
system which we've spoken about before
on this series it's just unfortunate
that it's attached to this Abomination
don't get me wrong it does look cool and
it almost looks like if FN decided to
make a P90 A2 with a new receiver
molding they might well make it look
like that in a way it looks a bit nicer
so it's not not a bad design don't get
me wrong but it's absolutely not a P90
and I don't know why not
negative on Hassan
negative no eyes on the hbt
one iced
[Music]
that's neutralized all right MP7 I have
got one of our mp7s our only um select
fire MP7 it has the no bullets one
bullet
all the bullets uh symbology on it which
is always interesting this is another
oddly redesigned gun you know if you
squint it's quite close the real
giveaway is the lack of this distinctive
slanted end cap on here which even games
that do a really hyper stylized MP7 tend
to include because it's it's quite a big
part of the silhouette of the gun
um here it's straight all the angles are
wrong basically except the shape around
the trigger guard so this this sort of
ramped up section here is represented
but for example the selector lever is on
backwards and works the other way around
so it's really quite strange because
you've got this flat fronted receiver
but then an angled receiver at the back
which almost makes it look like the gun
is backwards it's not but it does kind
of look a bit that way
foreign
foreign
liking the look of this actually I'm
gonna have some issues with the
furniture on this by which we mean the
handguard well probably not pistol grip
and the butt stock this is the HK Echo
[ __ ] 21 Model 21 so hk21 this is an
hk21a1 so it's this um the first
generation HK plastic lower receiver
effectively I'm quite taken with the
reload I think that's that's good in
fact all the all the weapons handling in
this game so far is really really good
very very naturalistic very well done no
obvious mistakes that I've seen I say
that in the case of this weapon because
it does have quite an unusual setup
being designed originally or the
platform at least for box magazines
detachable box magazines this is of
course a belt fed take on the H and K
roller as they call it roller locked
system they've essentially modeled this
well I think they've modeled this
correctly so instead of a top cover with
a feed tray like on most machine guns
lift it up here this this weapon
operates just like in the game with a
pivoting feed tray on the bottom so a
little bit awkward potentially compared
to a top loading Machine Gun there's a
reason why most belt vent machine guns
are top loading but essentially you pull
your your belt out from here lay it
across the feed tray
having locked the bolt open just like
the reload animation lock that into
place slap the handle bolt goes forward
first round is chambered first link
comes flying out the soil dropping out
the side and you're ready to shoot and
of course being an HK
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
so the camouflage on this is good enough
that it's actually a bit hard to tell
what the weapon is but I do like the way
they've done the camouflage scream
netting kind of moving around
realistically on the scope there we've
got stuff wrapped around the gun and I
think the suppressor as well
semi-disguising what is actually a take
on the Barrett mrad multi-role adaptive
design which was developed from a rifle
we do have called the m98b and here is
the now sadly old-fashioned Barrett m98b
the most obvious change apart from the
color I think they're all sort of desert
tan now is a folding more modular more
adjustable buff stock than the integral
about stock on the original 98b this is
all one aluminum forging here big old
well not that big but a big muzzle break
on the front for The Recoil this is a
338 lap of a magnum
I think the gun is meant to be in the
game is meant to be uh 300 I'm guessing
300 Norma which is a substantially more
powerful than even I think 300 Win which
is the Magnum so would a would a 300 or
even a 338 cause that level of
Destruction uh I don't think so but um
let's not dwell on that too much it's a
dramatic effect for the purposes of the
game it's it's probably a bit Ott
oh
[Music]
thank you
very clear
the nap uh the venerable Kalashnikov of
course is in this game and I think
there'd be some sort of Riot possibly in
the real world if it wasn't and it is so
that's fine we've clearly got different
configurations available so the version
I'm looking at here looks quite a bit
like the ak-203 but for some reason it
has not only the side rail which is an
old 1970s vintage Mountain solution for
optical sites on the AK on the left-hand
side but also the picatinny rail top
cover of something like the ak-200
series they don't come with both and I'm
sure you could build an AK that has both
I'm not sure why you would because
you've got that slightly bit slight bit
of added weight on the left hand side
for basically no reason because it's
provided your top cover fits properly
and maintains zero for your site you
wouldn't ever want to mount something on
the old-fashioned side rail now weirdly
grenade launcher yep absolutely AKs have
grenade launchers they don't I'm not
aware of a Picatinny type mount for the
GP 30 series which is what we're on at
the moment but weirdly in the in the HUD
it's called an m203 obviously it's not
an m203 unless m203 now stands for
grenade launcher and about grenade
launcher yeah it should be called
whatever it's meant to be gp25 gp30 gp34
uh what we do we do have Faithfully
represented the muzzle loading nature of
the GP series of Soviet and now Russian
grenade launchers where you shove The
Round In from the front but I don't
think anyone's got that wrong as yet and
I've now been presented with a truly
horrific
because of course uh gold-plated and
Chrome plated
Abomination that I'm now going to have
to look at yeah this is really over the
top we we do have a former Iraqi regime
gold-plated collection called in this
collection this that looks tasteful
compared to this thing this is two-tone
with the receiver in Chrome various
details in Chrome and then some of the a
lot of the rest of it in gold plate and
it absolutely does scream Mexican drug
cartel so I suspect that's the that's
the if there is a context to this that's
probably where this has come from and in
terms of it having rails and accessories
on it yep those guys absolutely do
follow the Fashions and accessorize
their guns some of them are more
old-school but yeah some of them are
quite up to date and quite Gucci as the
uh as the saying goes
foreign
James Bond pistol action here that's the
pistol is the six hour P220 we have a
very spangly looking version here golden
controls gold-plated trigger Hammer
decocking lever magazine catch slide
lock
and a sort of custom polished slide
finish and then on the top and if you
can see that on this camera but it's a
Sig Medallion but to be honest I'm more
interested in the gameplay here because
we've got an awful lot of underwater
pistol shooting firstly pistols or
Firearms generally don't cycle very well
underwater you've got well you know
water's incompressible but it can move
out of the way when it's in the body the
slide will move to the rear but just
like if you have your thumb against it
or something it won't necessarily come
far enough back to fully cycle which
means if I had one shot
and then
nothing happens what we shall call
pistol caliber bullets for the purposes
of this of this conversation goes so
slowly relative to rifle caliber bullets
that they are slowed right down coming
out of the muzzle so you get one shot
off because the mechanism is probably
not going to cycle fully and then the
bullet will slow down so within
definitely no more than two meters
probably less that bullet is going to be
completely non-lethal John Wick 3
covered this quite nicely with the
little pool where he's shooting
underwater and the two of them are
trying to shoot each other and the
bullets just go which means this is all
nonsense you can't Swan around shooting
people whilst underwater
Swan around oh I didn't even mean no I
didn't
okay I had to squint a bit at this rifle
because I'm pretty sure it's based on
the FN SCAR but a bit like the not P90
this is not a scar the lower receiver is
really quite different the enlarged
trigger guard the scar has like a fairly
slick sided shape to the low receiver
orbit with the beveled magazine well
this has a weird light lightening panel
cut into the side of it which makes it
look quite different but the
ambidextrous magazine catch lever is a
bit of a giveaway as to what the
inspiration is here as is the well some
of the design cues on the upper receiver
it's more like a scar than it is
anything else and the made-up French
name on the side would also suggest that
it's trying to be Belgian or not be
Belgian for whatever reason and I think
that makes this probably the most scary
is probably that take on the what's
sometimes called the Ugg boot buttstock
because it especially in the brown it
looks like a looks like an ugly
so when you when you switched your
pistol which as we all know is quicker
than reloading you get rid of your rifle
and you pull out your pistol and you do
a two-handed hold on it it seems what
they've now added is when you run out of
the ammunition on your rifle as you will
see in some tactical drills the shooter
takes their firing hand off the pistol
grip holds the rifle to one side draws
the pistol with one hand and should
continue shooting with the pistol so
you're effectively it's a it's a
temporary solution I've seen it in
action movies certainly where you defend
yourself or whatever with the pistol
re-holster that then you get back to
reloading your rifle so it's even
quicker than switching to your pistol so
it makes sense that Call of Duty as a
franchise would be the first to
represent that so I do appreciate that
foreign
guys I know you were probably waiting
for that one those are the guns of
Modern Warfare two
two as I'm now going to call it hope you
enjoyed it uh if you like what I'm doing
here perhaps you'd like to head over to
the Royal armories YouTube channel and
see what we're doing over there as a UK
National Museum we have three sites you
can come and visit obviously harder if
you're not in the UK but if you're ever
in this area this part of the world
please do come and see us you can also
check out our Facebook Instagram Twitter
accounts if you would like but whatever
you do see us again here next week
foreign
[Music]